fill in the blanks to complete the
equation so they have 76 830 is equal to
six ten thousands plus blank thousands
plus eight hundreds plus three tens
so let's just think about seventy six
thousand eight hundred and thirty so if
we write 76
and
30. i'm going to try to color code it
830.
we could write this out as being the
same thing this is being this is the
same thing as seventy thousand
plus six thousand the seven is in the
ten thousands place it's seven ten
thousands which is seventy thousand
plus the six is in the thousands place
so it's six
thousand
or six thousands one could say plus
eight hundred
or you could say eight hundreds
eight hundred plus three tens or thirty
plus three
tens
or thirty and then there's a zero one so
we could just write that out as zero if
we like
now what we have on the right here is
almost what they have on the right over
here notice the zero they didn't write
that so we can ignore that the zero
really doesn't affect the value
we have three tens we have three tens
we have
we have let me just in the color you can
see you have eight hundreds you have
eight hundred
you have but then that's where it starts
to break down they have blank thousands
here we have six thousands so we have to
think about this a little bit and then
they have six ten thousands which is
sixty thousand here there's only they
have we have seventy thousands so we
gotta work through we gotta work through
these two places right over here so they
have six ten thousands which is the same
thing as sixty thousand we have seventy
thousand so they essentially took ten
thousand from here and regrouped it
someplace and since these two places are
the same they must have regrouped it
into the thousands place so let's try to
do that so let's get rid of seventy
thousand let's get rid of ten thousand
out of the seventy thousand it becomes
sixty thousand so this becomes a six and
then we're regrouping that into the
thousands place so we're going to add
we're going to add 10 000
to the thousands place now what's the
thousands place going to be then well
it's 10 000 plus 6000 it's going to
become 16. it's going to become 16
thousands this right over here is going
to become a 16. so now what we wrote
here looks just like what they wrote up
here this is six ten thousands plus
sixteen
thousands
plus eight hundreds plus three tens and
we're done